tom tom has no problem going on a
podcast and under delivering
like
i don't know i [ __ ] love the guy but
i always say to him i don't understand
why people like you because i know why i
like you but why does brad pitt like you
like like what did brad pitt see because
he didn't see the thing i saw it's like
it's like when people say they they like
my wife i go you're not seeing oliver
like i know everything about that woman
like i like that you like her but you
don't know her like get to know her how
do you what brad pitt likes them what do
you break piss tom's one of tom's good
friends oh really yeah they're like best
friends i think and so yeah i know it's
brad pitt liked his comedy and uh and
clearly he just hadn't seen me do it and
and uh because i'm so much better and so
so i was waiting for someone to laugh at
that joke
but uh but um he
saw stand up like to stand up had they
had the same agent and he reached out to
his agency and was like hey man can you
give me tickets to tom show and [ __ ] and
he went in this whole time show and i
saw that on instagram yeah that was
really [ __ ] cool yeah because i'm a
huge brad pitt fan i mean who is it and
i'll tell you what i'll be honest with
you because jackass made brad pitt cool
brad pitt was
it it wasn't legends of the fall
think of all the movie stars that have
had great movies that are [ __ ] right
he did when you guys kidnapped him in
gorilla outfits in jackass
you were like this guy's got a sense of
humor he made it like bro it made him a
bro he likes cool stuff snapping was not
in a gorilla outfit and then we did the
gorilla bit after oh yeah yeah the
kidnapping was just curious about that
he's like we got brad pitt why are you
covering his [ __ ] face
and bam made a point
it was so cool at the end when he took
his gorilla mask off that was bread pit
and then and then i was like oh yeah you
could have done so much crazier stuff
with those gorillas and then just use
that last clip
right and when meanwhile he was like do
not go easy on me
like [ __ ]
that's what makes you like brad pitt
like those moments you know i saw him
driving one of his motorcycles down
sunset one time
dude the gl the leather gloves he had on
i think i think about those once a week
i mean he's just a badass [ __ ]
yeah i mean there's look
i'm a sucker for celebrity okay like i
am i like sure if you want to tell me a
story about my trainer trained tom
cruise for like
like all the mission impossible movies
all the all the big jack reacher all of
them when she tells me tom cruise
stories i should [ __ ] listen i love a
good tom cruise story and so
i i love i um when i moved out to la i
was a sucker for celebrity i thought it
was that was cool it was cool that
someone was famous and then you see them
and you'd be like you're like that's the
[ __ ] guy i mean i i saw mike tyson in
an elevator one time and i was like it's
the [ __ ] heavyweight chair empty
champ of the world that's mike tyson
possibly one of the greatest boxers that
ever lived he's in an elevator at the
lemley center where i'm going to crunch
and he's just in an elevator and i was
like holy [ __ ] what year was that
because it was night that was uh 2000 it
was 2002 2001. so that was a gnarly mic
yeah and it was right after that was
right after um i remember was after 9 11
because i remember being in an elevator
and someone was saying some stock
brokers on the phone and he's like no no
we need to buy
southwest
southwest is the company that is going
to stand out during all this stuff with
911 and i remember going i'd never heard
of southwest
it's called stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole and if you go on amazon and
type in stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole and order yourself a bottle
you'd be really helping me because right
now we're ranked number 30 on all of
amazon and if you buy a bottle we might
go up the ladder and that would mean a
lot so please get on amazon and buy
stevo's hot sauce for your butthole
yeah
yeah dude